alors maintenant on va terminer avec
c'est le premier league le sujet le
premier sert ou dessert c'est le milli a
travaillé en 1955 parce qu'ils voulaient
fixer dans sa mémoire ce qui était une
aventure personnelle le fait que sont sa
trajectoire de prisonniers politiques
ce soit confondue avec une grande
affaire politique qui est la vente des
secrets de la bombe atomique et le la
prise de possession par l'urss de la
home atomique alors ça il avait fixé
dans sa mémoire et il pensait bien
il a écrit plusieurs versions de ce
livre il en écrit alors oui alors cette
fois de l'entité il a écrit quatre
raquettes mais c'est là combien c'est le
huitième bercy c'est le huitième c'est
le 8ème alors c'est la liste version
c'est inouï et le nombre de de verscio
qu'elle eut attentes en urss qu'en
occident
parce que payer c'est à dire que
soljenitsyne n'était pas absolument sûr
que ce livre ne puisse pas sortir en
union soviétique dont après plusieurs
versions qui ont tous disparu qui ont
été cachés ou qui l'a détruite
il avait créé une version dans l'espoir
qu'elle voie le jour parce qu'ils
étaient eux-mêmes un auteur reconnu
après une journée d'ivan denissovitch et
voyant le tournant qu'a pris la
politique soviétique après 56 il pensait
pouvoir publier un livre qui raconte est
au fond un épisode du règne de staline
certains chapitres ont été publiés nous
dans nos vies mieux non absolument non
la veine on a essayé il a beaucoup lutté
pour en imposer la publication c'est en
partie ce qu'il raconte dans son dans
son le chêne élevé dans l'histoire de
ses démêlés avec la censure et avec la
rédaction de nourrir il n'a pas réussi
et à ce moment-là il
il a réécrit une c'est parce qu'il avait
naturellement autocensure et son texte
pour le rendre acceptable
ils avaient altéré l'intriguent au lieu
d'une intrigue atomique qui avait un
fondement historique qui est attestée
d'autres témoins que lui quelque chose
de réel il avait proposé une vague
collaboration un vad
la communication d'un secret un savant
soviétique où ça vient et étrangère ils
avaient ils avaient altéré le
l'essentiel de la crise d'autre part il
n'avait pas été aussi loin dans la
peinture de staline vieillissant il
était retenu aussi par certaines
considérations de prudence ils nous
épatent renommer le paquet b tel quel
par exemple parce que là alors
maintenant nous allons maintenant c'est
une oeuvre qui s'est accompli parce que
vous vous souvenez que dans un rocker du
livre l'auteur narrateur parce que il
raconte une tranche considérable de sa
propre vie devant la une brimade qui est
imposée aux prisonniers l'auteur se dit
les victimes oublieront ils sont furieux
on les a privés d'une visite mais le
temps va passer et ils oublieront mais
moi je suis là pour me souvenir 4 cloud
un nom et ce sera pour l'éternité fixée
donc c'est parce qu'il il entend
transformer sa mémoire personnelle en
une mémoire historique qu'il décide de
se souvenir de tout c'est pourquoi après
les tentatives pour faire publier son
livre il décide de l'autre recréer tel
qu'il aurait voulu le faire c'est à dire
sans qu'un seul détail puissent être
imputés à la peur d'une censure quel con
c'est à dire qu'il représente une sorte
de coquettes sur la peur et sur le
mensonge
c'est un livre qui se présente comme un
roman policier vous l'avez lu au début
n'est ce pas un diplomate soviétique
très jeune très brillant est accoutumé à
l'occident c'est que le la bombe
atomique doit être livré à des espions
soviétiques aux états unis il pense à ce
moment là que les cuivres du monde va
s'en ressentir de façon peut-être
irréparable il prend sur lui de
téléphoner à un voile ambassade du
canada
il tombe sur un conseiller je ne
comprends pas ce qu'il veut dire
ils font même le mot de bombes atomiques
à ce qu'on la communication est coupée
et on passe du monde de la diplomatie
soviétique au cabinet ou des
spécialistes ont pour mission d'écouter
les ambassades et ont donc pas la porte
du kgb on entre dans un
une voie qui est celle du secret
politique et c'est comme ça qu'on
pénètre dans cette espèce de monde clos
et l'achat racheta qui est un institut
scientifique ou des prisonniers élabore
un système permettant d'identifier les
voies sur écoute téléphonique de façon à
dépister les esprits au possible
et soudain coup on va du simple fait qu
on entre dans ce monde
lyon va se se structurer toute une
société autour de l'ordre donné d'en
haut par staline société entièrement
composé de prisonniers et de prix pas
car les bourreaux sont aussi prisonnier
que les prisonniers eux-mêmes est au
centre de cet extraordinaire monde
staline enfermé dans son bunker dotés de
l'air conditionné vieillissant et
commence à perdre lui même de sa propre
mémoire très peu sollicité entre dans ce
monde au moment où le tir en
vieillissant commence à sombrer dans le
gâtisme mais qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
ce génie dans cette chasse est bien en
tant que mathématicien il avait été
retiré du camp de concentration et on
l'utilisait pour ses talents comment
utiliser ailleurs du mathématicien et
physicien des des choux d'heure des
photographes
comment ses talents de quel talent
mathématicien maintenant oui il était
mathématicien pour qu'on l'utilisé dans
un labo pour faire des 60's opération
mathématique il y a dû rester trois ans
dans le livre est d'ailleurs est dédié à
mes amis d'achat oui parce que dans ce
dans ce dans cet institut qui était
situé près de moscou et qui travaillait
à cette question ultra confidentiel il y
avait quelques uns de ses meilleurs amis
d'autres dont certains sont connus comme
écrivain par ailleurs le spa compagnie
new hope nf et qu'ils ont eux même
laissé des souvenirs sur cette période
de leur vie où ils ont collaboré à ce
projet de des chiffres projet de
déchiffrage de la voie téléphonique
qu'il devait être une des clefs du
système de
des coupes soviétique alors ça c'est
pour l'aspect disons politique du roman
mais j'aurais aussi qu'on assiste et là
je demanderai la vie de monsieur dit m
tomasz puisque vous êtes traducteur
connaissez bien le russe alors il va y
avoir de la qualité littéraire parce que
souvent on dit ça je dis oui
historiquement c'est formidable mais les
pires errements certains font la fine
bouche on va avoir quelques élèves votre
avis tous les deux caisses le penser que
ce génie zina vraiment une qualité
littéraire est ce qu'il explique dans
son livre war fait ce jour-là à damas je
ne nie pas le rush suffisamment bien au
fond lire un grand romancier comme ce
geste your skin louis borredon que je ne
peux le juge et non à travers la
traduction au jeu direct star grand
romancier bon et vous alors ah mais oui
si vous voulez ce qui m'a frappé dans ce
dans ce texte j'ai eu à traduire ces
cons sans fin dans la composition tout
entière de liberté plein cours beauquis
parce que ça lui l'architecturé
parfaitement solide défense suisse est
un des personnages on voit ce se
construit tout un monde avec que staline
les ministres les plus redoutables et
des simples chef de cabinet on va
jusqu'au portier jusqu'au tout petit
personnel et elle c'est tout un monde
avec toute la russie derrière des normes
fragments de son histoire qui se compose
chapitre après chapitre sans qu'on perd
jamais le fil choc que chapitre
éclairant tous les autres avec une
vigueur face et moi l'impression que
j'ai eue c'est passionnant d'une rigueur
et presque d'allégresse ils nous paient
un monde dort plus et un monde heureux
plus gouvernée par un tir en mourant est
enfermé lui même et il nous raconte
cette terrible histoire d'hommes sans
femmes d'hommes son destin sans avenir
qui sont voués à re sombrer dans le
goulag avec une allégresse qui n'est pas
dû à parce qu'il dépeint mais à une
espèce de liberté qu'il accomplit sur
lui-même et à mon avis c'est un point
unique dans le soja
je crois oui je crois que c'est un ton
unique parce que c'est il ya là une
sorte de 2,2 faurie
d'une victoire remportée sur le sur le
mal sur le mensonge vous viens vous dire
que pour un an comme seul génie tine il
s'agit avant tout de récupérer sa langue
de de ce2 force de se faire un langage
dans un monde qui est privé de langage
fall le propre de la du monde soviétique
c'est qui les régit notamment par un
discours fictif le discours socialiste
soviétique qui imprègne toute chose
depuis les crèches jusqu'aux os place
monumentale un canon célèbre constamment
une réalité qui n'est pas c'est une
immense publicité qui vendrait un
produit inexistant qui est le communisme
et cela par les conseils d une
rhétorique 110 normand envahissante
répétitives
cet homme là a dû se crée sa langue se
créer un langage affranchi de cette
oppression du mensonge et je pense que
là la joie qu'il aa à se sentir maître
d'un instrument lui permet de dire ce
qu'il veut et pour beaucoup dans la
composition tout à fait efficace et dur
et glissante de ce qu'est ce qu'il voit
c'est que quand on lire ce roman ça
s'adresse aux jeunes un grand architecte
c'est un immense archipel
ça c'est évident après avoir l'avis
d'andré brink est de devenir dit qu'est
ce que vous pensez
ce gène ici comment dieu en angleterre
c'est le tasse à thé ou pas je peux pas
dire que je que je lui ai aime parce que
ça c'est un mot trop floue gv ou
admiration immense pour lui pour moi
c'est une lumière dans une ténèbres que
l'on voit toujours autour de soi est
l'exemple qu'il donne est surtout à
l'époque où il écrivait ceci où se
trouvait toujours au milieu de cette
situation vous coincer les jeux c'est un
des plus grandes oeuvres de de notre
époque devenir vie
se dessine est admirable et nous l'avons
dit précédemment cette forme qu'il a
donnée d'un roman particulièrement l'ont
fait qu'il est indispensable de
retrouver cette vigueur
c'est une condition sine qua none pour
un roman de jean essentiellement chez
seul dieu nissin on trouve une espèce de
colère qui lui donne cette jubilation
cette joie cette gaieté et cette joie
qu'ils aient pourra enfin être devenu
lui-même un témoin à pouvoir dit ma
vérité autour de lui et quelle que soit
la source de cette énergie est
nécessaire qu'il puisse la faire
irradier autour de lui et qu'on retrouve
ce fil d'ariane à travers toute son
oeuvre comme vous l'avez dit vous-même
et je pense personnellement que c'est un
très grand écrivain très fort très
vigoureux encore que jamais je n'ai lu
par plaisir jamais je n'ai lu par
plaisir j'ai lu en raison de sa
puissance
enfin je le pratique l'humain et la
puissance d'après moi n'est pas au
mariage
on n'est pas si vous voulez l'une des
choses que je recherche avec plaisir
lorsque je lis mais je pense que il faut
d'une manière ou d'une autre se donner à
autrui s'imprégner d'autrui et dans ma
bouche est un compliment lorsque je vous
dis cela
il est avec tous les romans de thomas
sarde et je retrouve cela je trouve
cette vérité on ne choisit pas tel ou
tel roman de thomas hardy et on ne vit
pas dans l'idéal on ne dit pas non plus
de façon décontractée quelques pages
on voulait totalement imprégné on se
baigne dans ce livre dans ce roman
taille on est isolé de tout le reste et
on est en quelque sorte consommer parce
qu'on est en train d'y bon oui martin ça
c'est le